that other model we mentioned it's a
draft federal government model based on
preliminary data and it warns of dire
consequences if reopening is not done
with proper care
the scenario planning information as
it's known is based on research
developed by john hopkins
and it says average daily death toll
from this virus could nearly double to 3
000 by june 1st
president trump has been publicly
encouraging states to reopen of course
paula reid is at the white house for us
paula good morning what is the president
saying about all this
good morning tony in an interview last
night with a new york post the president
said
he's never seen this document but the
researchers who did this analysis
say their data was preliminary and it
wasn't supposed to be used to make
predictions
but they do concede that there are some
scenarios especially if social
distancing is eased too soon
that could result in a significant
increase in the number of people who die
from coronavirus president trump called
the document
fake but cbs news has learned the slide
presentation
is based on preliminary analysis
developed by researchers at the johns
hopkins school of public health
and presented to fema in a statement the
school said the results were not to be
used as
forecasts but illustrate that some
scenarios
like relaxing social distancing too soon
are likely to cause significant
increases in covid cases and deaths in
the u.s
dr anthony fauci said that while models
can change based on the assumptions
entered
the core principles don't when you have
mitigation that's containing something
and unless it's down in the right
direction
and you pull back prematurely you're
going to get a rebound of cases
and while the president dismissed the
fema document even the white house's
preferred model the ihme
has nearly doubled its prediction of
lives lost
and over the past two months the
president has repeatedly revised
his estimate it's looking like it's
heading to 50 000 or more deaths
it looks like we'll be at about a 60 000
mark
we're going to lose anywhere from 75
80 to 100 000 people cbs news chief
medical correspondent dr john lepuc
says models are useful for policy making
the coronavirus pandemic is one big
moving target so it's not at all
surprising that as the data changes the
projections are going to change
the important thing is to look at those
changes in the projections and say
maybe i should alter my strategy if the
projections are different than i thought
they were going to be
the trump administration though seems
unmoved by these dire new predictions
a top white house adviser told cbs news
yesterday
they believe that these new models
actually support what the administration
has done so far
later this morning the president will
head to arizona where he will tour
an aerospace factory has been converted
to make personal protective equipment
gail all right thank you paul the big
question today will the president wear a
mask we'll see